messieurs bonsoir ce soit encore et pour
le sixième jour consécutif la plupart
des journalistes d'antenne 2 sont en
grève par solidarité avec le personnel
de la fft ce journal vous sera donc
présenté par des journalistes et les
techniciens requis dans le cadre du
programme minimum conformément à la loi
nous avons besoin de revenir dans le
courant de ce journal sur les
développements de la crise de la dette
mais d'abord l'iran l'iran qui ce matin
a définitivement changé de visage
une seule loi celle du coran un seul
régime celui de monsieur bah d'argan
premier ministre désigné par l'ayatollah
khomeiny et qui s'est déjà installé dans
le fauteuil de chapleau bakar chapour
bakhtiar qui serait vivant je vous le
dis tout de suite il serait réfugié à
quelques kilomètres de téhéran tout cas
elle ne s'est pas suicidé comme le bruit
en avait couru hier
de toute façon tous les bastions qu'il
soutenait sont tombés aujourd'hui l'un
après l'autre la garde impériale s'est
rendue la fameuse gare de noir qui donne
au chat le commandant en chef des armées
a été exécuté
l'ancien premier ministre aux pays-bas a
été extrait de la prison pour être
présenté à la presse aujourd'hui propose
maintenant de suivre en images le film
heure par heure de ces deux jours
d'insurrection sanglante qui ont amené
la victoire de la révolution en iran
gym le matin les derniers bastions sont
tombées aux mains des révolutionnaires
notamment le centre de torture de la tam
ac et surtout la garde impériale et 80
m2 est rendu ce matin à la caserne de la
garde impériale
on avait déjà dit et le drapeau blanc et
le portrait de gavin
la foule s'est alors précipitée
l'intérêt
alors il filme
la ville d'ataq notre cameraman bernard
gagné
et capturé
à part quelques membres de la garde
impériale il ne pouvait accepter leur
défaite
sa caméra en face des métriques
on est pire est alors de votre café il
est complet
ce que personne ne peut disputer
et le brutal effondrement de l'armée
dont on vante et la pop la loyauté et la
discipline et l'iranien m'a dit
aujourd'hui encore tout surpris
finalement cette armée n'était qu'un
tigre de papier problème qui se pose
désormais
à côté
non
elle pue
gp2
le peuple rendent les armes respectives
ambassades et fait
parlant du chat la tâche ne sera pas y
avait c'est seulement à ce
pourtant entamé la mise en place de
l'enquêté publique
ouais je précise bien que les images que
vous voulez voir m'ont pas aidé tournée
par une équipe vingtaine de nos envoyés
spéciaux la bat philipp n'ait vous l'a
dit ont été molestés ce matin à teyran
par la foulée par les militaires notre
cameraman bernard vallier mais aussi
notre photographe yves laurent ils ont
été gelées rappellent cruellement pris à
partie cela fait bien sûr partie de ce
que l'on appelle entre les risques du
métier mais je voulais que vous pouvez
pas nier que parfois ce métier était
difficile avec le recul maintenant
serge me serais de paris tente
d'analyser les conséquences de la
victoire de la révolution islamique a
traversé 48 heures d'émeutes ça je me
serais adhérents aujourd'hui les
manifestants ce dernier par le climat de
violence qui règne dans le pays ont
mises à sac incertaine d'édifices
publics et il a fallu que l'ayatollah
intervienne personnellement à la radio
et menaces pour que cessent les saccages
tente il est vrai que lorsqu'on a
déclenché des forces populaires aussi
violentes que celles qui ont renversé ce
qui restait du régime du shah il est
parfois difficile de les arrêter
commencée vendredi le sens il allait
être là a été totale des civils armés
jusqu'aux dents se sont mises à attaquer
des casernes après un semblant de
résistance
les soldats commençaient tu as rome peu
à peu au rythme désormais assister à la
décomposition progressive de tout ce qui
avait été mise en place en plusieurs
décennies par le shah et son père
monsieur au barca a résisté bien encore
mais à mesure que l'insurrection gagne
et la rue on la laisse apercevoir que
cette résistance devenait impossible
des éléments de l'armée à s'affronter
dimanche des soldats fidèles à monsieur
bart hier contre d'autres aux soldats
passés dans le camp de l'ayatollah et
puis peu avant 13h tombe d'un communiqué
des militaires qui affirme leur
neutralité
en d'autres termes ils viennent de
lâcher monsieur p o
tout allait très vite à 15 heures
monsieur bastien démissionnaire à 16
heures on le dit enfui à l'étranger puis
suicider en fait on ne sait toujours pas
où est passé monsieur bart ya le
processus s'accélère les casernes club
les unes après les autres les soldats se
rallient même d'alternate airial prête
serment nouveau régime radio tomber
humanisation j'ai dit sue désordre les
messages de l'ayatollah et mises à part
quelques petits îlots de résistance
david
de l'arménie apparaît totale
après le début de son offensive voici
donc l'ayatollah m de l'iran et il va
comme il a promis d'installer cette
république islamique que dans un réflexe
d'autodéfense contre l'occidentalisation
progressive de leur pays les iraniens
viennent d'appeler et donc plus qu'un
seul régime légal à teyran aujourd'hui
solide pour le ministre base arguant du
carter l'a déjà reconnu et cela c'est un
signe qui ne trompe points peu de temps
après le personnel de l'ambassade d'iran
à paris c'est à se rallier au nouveau
premier ministre pour le déroulement de
la journée
quelle que soit la force de ce qu'on
appelle le flux d'histoire nous avons
toujours essayé ici de garder la tête
froide car rien n'est jamais tout blanc
ou tout noir
et il se trouve aujourd'hui de plus en
plus de dire à nier d'iraniennes à se
montrer aussi inquiets d'une possible
dictature de m aulas et ses amis qu'il
ne l'était de celle du chat écoutez ce
témoignage recueilli par jacques à
bouchard première plan pour moi c'est
les femmes qui vont beaucoup souffrir
parce qu'elle a pu jouer un voile doit
être respectée parce que tu m'as main ou
en âge des femmes deux fameux gala un
homme parce que la femme adultère doit
être lapidée et il y en a beaucoup d'eux
parce que je peux y aller très loin des
brimades contre les femmes mais vous
pensez également contre d'autres
catégories
ah oui pas religieux religieux des
minorités religieuses des juifs des
barrages des chrétiens des arméniens des
héros est rien vous pensez qu'ils sont
persécutés
je pense qu'ils souffriront beaucoup
c'est sûr ils ont déjà peur tout les
magasins brûlés saudeau magasin
d'arméniens mais c'est parti à la rose
et de faire face et pour moi c'était
vraiment un angle libéral qui lave et
c'est sincèrement faut penser que bastia
était une
le chance pour l'iran de sortir de la
vitarelle chance parce que toutes sont à
7,10 à des années de prison de cham et
et ça vous voyez le travail avec mon
sabre pour libérer le pétrole tout ce
qu'il a fait tout son passé mettez ça
alors pourquoi selon vous ses anciens
amis de l'opposition dont ils tellement
condamnés selon moi parce que le full
est vert khomeiny de fil 4g ne convainc
pas le full c'est moi aussi le chevrolet
règne je ne condamne pas dit tout
mais je trouve qu'on s'accroche un peu
n'importe quoi qu'on souffre beaucoup et
cette population armée tous ces civils
vous pensez que qui sont derrière
l'ayatollah comédie vous pensez qu'ils
sont tous des religieux non ils sont
tous pour le moment qu'on est unis va
avoir beaucoup de difficultés c'est
maintenant l'heure des réactions pas de
réaction officielle du gouvernement
français en revanche une terrible
inquiétudes chez les voisins de l'iran
lui à s attaquer à accepter mais de tous
les pays le plus marqué est sans
conteste croit israël qui n'a pas de
frontière commune avec l'iran mais le
qui dépend son approvisionnement
pétrolier et surtout dans une certaine
mesure sa sécurité en a c'est ma main
la paire iranienne est pourri frêle
lourde de conséquences dans l'immédiat
est chargé de bellaing pour un athée
proche avenir et agissez de la vie
privée de sa principale ressource en
pétrole un pétrole qui rappelons le
cours étaient propres besoins et lui
assurer grâce aux pays bas et un rouge
méditerranée des revenus assez
considérable il est aussi pourri médian
le sort de près de 70 milles qui
pourrait demain comme les familles l'ubs
syrie être des nodingues nouveau régime
avec l'aide de grandes puissances
européennes et en premier lieu la france
israël pourrait tenter d'obtenir
l'évacuation des enfants juifs d'iran
pour le proche avenir le ralliement de
terrain hondurien est rien moins qu
rassurant et vient renforcer
dangereusement les fronts est et nord
d'israël que bagdad et damas pourrait
être tenter de réactiver
c'est dans cette perspective
encourageante que vont s'ouvrir
entretien de camp david ii oui israël
serait moins disposés qu'auparavant aux
concessions qui seront demandés en
échange de garanties américaines pour la
valeur est pour le moins évident
qu'israël et ce tout en un qui était de
la rapidité avec laquelle l'américain
d'abord lâché chapuis sous ce nouveau
régime révolutionnaire jimmy carter l'a
dit tout net il ya quelques heures les
etats-unis sont prêts à travailler avec
les nouveaux dirigeants avec lesquels
nous avons déjà noué des contacts il ya
quelque chose et quand on regarde à une
plus vaste échelle encore la liste
goupille abondé par washington
l'extrême orient formose l'afrique
aujourd'hui l'iran on peut se poser des
questions sur la valeur du soutien mais
qu'un et sur l'emploi de son repli dans
cette région stratégique
quatre cent mille hommes 600 avions les
états unis avaient équipé l'armée
iranienne de pied en cap pour en faire
son gendarme dans le golfe persique
quarante mille conseillers américains
instruisez cette armée dont la tâche
était de protéger
l'arabie saoudite et des émirats dont le
pétrole transitent par le détroit
d'ormuz débouché naturel vers l'océan
pour les tankers
régime iranien pratiquer une politique
foncièrement anti américaine les
etats-unis perdre non seulement le base
d'observations vers l'urss qui possède
frontières communes de plus de 2000 km
avec l'iran mais surtout ce sont tous
les producteurs de pétrole du golfe qui
tombent sous la menace directe de l'iran
et de ses éventuels nouveaux alliés
c'est cette crainte que le roi khaled
d'arabie saoudite a exprimé au
secrétaire d'état américain à la défense
actuellement en visite officielle à
ryadh car en perdant l'iran et ses 40
millions d'habitants washington doit
disparaître dans la région son seul
partenaire qui soit doté d'une véritable
force militaire qui dit appuyer mes
qualifs asseman influence grandissante
des soviétiques à l'instant j'apprends
la première réaction de moscou l'union
soviétique en reconnaît le gouvernement
provisoire de l'iran c'est ce que
monsieur boko signée diane annonce est
évident que dans ces conditions les
entretiens qu'a eus aujourd'hui jean
françois poncet le ministre français de
laval rongeurs avec les dirigeants
soviétiques
on tue un arrière-goût d'iran mais ils
ont été surtout centrée sur les
problèmes de détente et de désarmement
bernard pendant les soviétiques observe
un silence prudent sur ce sujet silence
il est vrai que l'on peut quand même
dans lequel on peut quand même percevoir
une certaine satisfaction l'on peut
manquer de noter que l'agent stone en
général assez lentes à répercuter les
événements internationaux
l'agent stahl a été l'une des premières
annonces la chute de monsieur bac
à noter aussi que la presse soviétique
sans faire de commentaire ne va pas
moins offert à ses lecteurs une version
des faits est extrêmement favorable à
l'ayatollah khomeini
alors on a un peu l'impression ce soir à
moscou que les soviétiques sont partagés
entre deux sentiments une paris ne sont
pas mécontents d'enregistrer les chefs d
enrique en iran et la victoire des
forces populaires ne l'avions prévu
rappelle ton volontiers à moscou mettait
aussi avec un peu d'inquiétude que l'on
voit se déstabiliser une région
stratégique à la frontière de laquelle
il ne faut pas l'oublier c'est entre les
républiques socialistes d'asie centrale
où l'islam demeure aujourd'hui très
vivant les mêmes termes en cause soutien
de moscou au gua l'embargo
prévente un tournant assez récents comme
la politique société un tournant
intéressant et qui s'opposent à des
hésitations qui était très voyante parce
que durant tout le développement de la
crise pratiquement jusqu'au départ du
shah ce qui frappait dans l'attitude
politique c'est que l'union soviétique
s'est abstenu absolument de tout
commentaire
elle n'a pas pu soutenir le ch a
bruyamment comme on fait les chinois
mais je prends qu'il faut tenir compte
de ce qu'ils opposent aux chinois et le
chinois y ont pris position pour le chat
moscou se devait d'être plus réservés
oui au moins pendant très longtemps la
presse soviétique n'a mentionné que de
désordre sans dire qu'ils étaient
dirigés contre le chili était dirigée
contre l'impérialisme et puis
tardivement on a appris au moment où
chaque fois de partir que c'était contre
le shah et quant à l'ayatollah khomeiny
et l'état paru quand j'étais parti donc
il ya vraiment eu un revirement très
très rapide et la rapidité sont traduits
dans cette reconnaissance immédiate
alors que l'union soviétique est en
général très très bas par le cyrano
basse mais ne pas courir absolument pas
les événements et je crois que ça montre
la perplexité soviétique et ça gêne
devant une révolution qui ne va pas
l'autre 20 de ses désirs il ya quand
même certaines illogisme à soutenir un
homme qui disent on est assez
conservateur pour autant qu'on sache
pour l'instant l'ayatollah khomeini oui
il y à un illogisme et adam g je compte
les deux sont vraies un illogisme parce
que ce que propose à l'iran l'ayatollah
khomeini va tout même à l'encontre de
toute la modernisation que l'union
soviétique trèche partout dans le monde
et puis que c'est une république
islamique dont quelque chose qui va à
l'encontre du matérialisme qu'il faut
mettre ces idées
cela dit il a pire ya le danger votre
correspondant le rappelait il y a des
frontières bordée de musulmans et 2500
km de frontière commune et des musulmans
de l'autre côté de la frontière de
musulmans qui nourrissent le rêve d'une
république islamique aussi échec il ya
non pas un réveil une survivance des
de la foi musulmane mais un projet
d'organisation est à tiko religieuse qui
est très net et qui suit à feu tantôt
les lignes d'un islam moderniste mettant
tous les lignes d'un islam conservateur
comme celui que prône la moto la commune
i alors les rendre l'ayatollah risque
d'apparaître comme modèle et lingala
parce que vous pensez comme dessinateur
du ce que l'ayatollah khomeiny et
représente une sorte de cheval de troie
dans lequel peau s infiltrait les
communistes je compris que vois je crois
qu'il peut être un cheval de troie dans
la mesure où je soupçonne qu'il n'ait
pas organisé et que les communistes
iraniens qui ont été entraînés en
allemagne orientale sont des gens
parfaitement organisé déjà implantés et
qui connaissent les leviers de commande
de l'ôta la honte à simuler je pense que
l'union soviétique doit aussi éviter car
on a longtemps cru que l'islam et le
communisme était compatible par sous le
communisme dévorer islam ont les
soviétiques que sont en train
d'apprendre sur leur exemple que la
compatibilité pour jouer parce que
l'islam des vers le communisme c'est ce
qui leur arrive et je crois que de voir
la même chose se développer à leur
frontière le pousse beaucoup de
problèmes je remercie autre foyer
d'incendié sur la carte du monde
aujourd'hui le tchad de la crise
politique qui opposait depuis plus de
trois mois le président malo masson
ancien premier ministre hissène habré a
brutalement
générer aujourd'hui on à l'affrontement
armé affrontements pour l'instant entre
les fronts les forces régulières
tchadienne
et puis celle de l'ancien chef des
rebelles du tout bouffer et celui qui
avait retenu en otage françoise coste
pour l'instant hissène habré aurait
réussi à s'enfuir chine ce n'est
qu'aujourd'hui que l'on vient
d'apprendre neuf nouvelles exécutions
qui serait produite à la mi janvier neuf
chinois dont une femme fusillé pour des
crimes de droit commun
et puis belgique toujours la crise plus
que jamais à son tour ville c'est martin
qui avait été chargé de former le
gouvernement vient de présenter sa
démission au roi baudouin enfin canada
avec la première journée de la visite
officielle de raymond barre dans ce que
l'on appelle la belle province est à
dire plus prosaïquement le québec c'est
finalement le chanteur gilles vigneault
qui la vedette de ce voyage au québec
sans que cela gêne aucunement monsieur
raymond barre viennent au contraire les
chansons de vigneault
les gens du pays est depuis deux jours
chanter dans une nouvelle adaptation que
vous avez entendu hier
cher monsieur bart à votre tour de vous
laisser parler d'amour
l'émotion ne saurait donc être absente
de ces rencontres légèrement contrarié
par le froid de -30 degrés cela dit
messieurs bar lévesque ont joué leur
partition
chacun dans son registre mais sans
aucune fausse note
le premier ministre français a rappelé
la phrase de monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing
quoi qu'il arrive le québec peut compter
sur la sympathie fraternelle de la
france monsieur rené lévesque le premier
québécois pour sa part n'a pas manqué
d'ironiser sur ottawa
ces deux attitudes étant confirmé ce
matin lors de la visite de raymond barre
à l'assemblée nationale ni relation
directe et fraternelle connaissent un
développement régulier
la france y contribuer dans le respect
des compétences du québec et avec le
souci constant de ne pas nous ingérer
dans les affaires intérieures
au canada personne ne saurait donc en
prendre le moindre bras votre venue
concrétiser amplifie des liens entre nos
deux pays
si impérieusement exigé par le passé et
par l'avenir que personne désormais ne
saurait raisonnablement songez vous à
les affaiblir ni encore moins les dix
titres pas une transition toute trouvée
pour nous amener à parler de l'actualité
française à commencer par l'actualité
politique marquée surtout par la
nouvelle caste sueur qui s'est confirmée
au sein de la majorité du parti
socialiste il hier soir peu avant minuit
on peut vraiment dire que la rupture est
consommée françois mitterrand d'une part
michel michel rocard parents et pierre
mauroy d'autre part iront au congrès de
metz en ordre dispersé les trois pour la
de nice sont d'ailleurs expliqué
aujourd'hui sur les raisons de leur
choix
pierre mauroy france inter estime que
finalement il était le seul à vraiment
souhaiter un accord michel rocard qui
est l'invité de notre journal 12h45
rejettent la responsabilité de ce
désaccord c'est à dire de l'absence de
synthèse sur françois mitterrand avant
hier il ya dix jours près pendant lequel
fonctionnait commission dite de la
synthèse qui a entrepris par respect
pour le premier ce cratère de ne pas
rédiger eux-mêmes en l'absence du
prestataire qui n'est pas mené une
émotion qu'on aurait fait tous ensemble
mais par la terre a fait savoir qu'il
faisait la sienne
nous avons attendu à ce que ce contexte
nous l'avait annoncé en séance et non
pas au début
ouaddou guidicelli ben khedda et c'est
une forme de comprimés salué françois
mitterrand ne voulait pas de synthèse
c'est bien ce que je crois d'ailleurs il
faut voir dans son mobile son lot de
signification c'est ainsi que j'ai
interprété la chose michel rocard estime
encore que françois mitterrand a eu un
comportement de droite qui l'a présenté
à un texte de combat le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste qui lui
est l'invité de tf1 va réagir à ces
propos et protesté de sa bonne foi
j'ai toujours déclaré que je souhaitais
une synthèse dans la clarté et sans
exclusif j'ai entendu plusieurs
responsables du parti socialiste annoncé
qu'il le ferait
l'accord qu'au congrès de metz je crois
avoir compris que michel rocard avait
déclaré à plusieurs reprises mais peu
importe où je reste ouvert disponible
jusqu'à demain soir sinon les décisions
du parti
waouh pour tout synthèse éventuel les
dirigeants socialistes se rejette donc
la responsabilité de la rupture à
quelques variantes près tous se
déclarent prêts à rediscuter
mais il est des mots qui reste et qui
ont peut-être fait trop mal exemple
cette phrase de françois mitterrand
s'adresse entière à pierre mauroy et
michel rocard leur disant je cite
messieurs les assassins à vous la parole
autre événement de la semaine la
conférence de presse de valéry giscard
d'estaing jeudi et je suis concentré sur
les problèmes de politique
internationale
l'actualité sociale maintenant avec
toujours deux points chauds la
sidérurgie et la sfp dans la sidérurgie
la cgt la cfdt la cftc force ouvrière
ont capté aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
salariés des mines de fer à une grève de
24 heures vendredi prochain par ailleurs
quelques 500 grévistes de cdf chimie ont
bloqué ce matin le train varsovie paris
en gare de saint-avold c'est à dire en
moselle parce que maintenant de la sfp
c'est à dire la société française de
production il faut s'attendre demain
encore un programme minimum partout à la
télévision et ce bien sûr à la suite du
mouvement de solidarité avec les
personnels
la ssp qui sont menacés de perdre leur
emploi la journée a été très houleuse à
la sft le pdg antoine de
clermont-tonnerre devait s'expliquer sur
les mesures qu'il avait décidé mais le
comité d'entreprise prévu n'a pas eu
lieu après la suspension du comité
d'entreprise le président antoine le
ferment tonnerre a été prise à partie
par des grévistes qui lui ont demandé de
venir s'expliquer devant l'assemblée
générale le président a accepté la
proposition est accompagné des
responsables syndicaux il est monté à la
tribune devant plusieurs centaines de
personnes et il a confirmé qu'il n'était
pas là pour liquider la sfp
mais pour assurer son redressement cet
après midi à 15 heures devant le conseil
d'administration à l' empire antoine de
clermont tonnerre a indiqué que le
gouvernement était disposé à accorder
une aide financière de 250 millions de
francs bourg à la fft
à condition que celle ci mette en oeuvre
le plan de redressement proposé qui
permettrait le retour à l'équilibré en
propre
j'ajoute que le de la ferme qui devait
se dérouler à l' empire n'aura pas lieu
non plus ce soir les personnels usfp et
qu'il avait prévu
on en a été empêché par la police et
s'excuse auprès du public et des
artistes qui l'avait invitée ou pas
c'est ce qui passe par une nouvelle
rencontre ce type cette fois rien ne
m'empêchera des styles j'ajoute et sans
aucun rapport avec ces événements que je
les émissions de réponses ont été
interrompues une bonne partie de la
journée à cause du froid ou plutôt du
dégel et puis que des inconnus ont
saccagé les studios de nos confrères de
fr3 grenoble dégâts très importants
maintenant un dossier dramatique qui
fait froid dans le dos depuis quelques
mois une soixantaine de bébés sont morts
à naples victime d'un mal mystérieux un
mal qui affecte les voies respiratoires
des nouveau nés et qui a fait cette nuit
sa 63e victimes
victor vraiment inquiété à naples
cette petite fille de neuf points va
mourir dans une dizaine de minutes
malgré tous les efforts des médecins de
la salle de réanimation de l'hôpital
santo bono de naples
ra câline lettieri sera la 60e victimes
de ce qu'on appelait le mal mystérieux
de naples qui tue les enfants âgés de
moins de 12 ans nous avons fumé une audi
et dix minutes plus tard allemand qu'est
ce qui s'est passé dans son coeur
hélas eu des des symptômes de branche it
et à quelques jeux et puis là
c'est un peu midi et les tombé dans le
coma et
il fait qu'une chose qui se passait d'un
plusieurs traits de ce dernier pain et
son 2e 5e ils ont des problèmes
respirez père est précoce et puis
de fait ils s'empêtrent est bien et puis
ils t'aiment balle comme impulsif 23
familles se sont installées dans cette
clinique désaffectée
deux se partagent trois cabinets c'est
un exemple
deux enfants sont morts cet hiver et la
troisième est à l'hôpital on dit même
que cela n'a rien d'exceptionnel que la
mortalité infantile a n'a pas toujours
été comparable à celle d'un pays du
tiers monde
la routine en somme la mère de l'un des
enfants décédés carrés 4 - habite encore
dans cet immeuble n'a fini radier mon
mari votre enfant l'humour
excusez moi si je vous le dis aussi beau
tellement j'ai protesté
pourquoi ne vous pas prévenue six à dix
le fumier vous envoyer les cabinets
carabine qui ne sont jamais vu si je
n'étais pas allé à l'hôpital n'avait
jamais su que mon fils était mort
j'attends du budget vous j'ai demandé à
voir mon fils ce n'était pas possible
parce qu'on était en train de lui faire
une autopsie
le tir dès famille napolitaine vivent
dans des conditions d'insalubrité totale
la saleté l'humidité la promiscuité
favorise les épidémies le mal mystérieux
ne peut tuer que des organismes
affaiblis
sans moyens naturels de défense c'est
évident on est tellement habitué aux
épidémies à naples qu'on ne sait même
pas demander si cette année la mort des
enfants n'était pas un peu trop violente
et plus fréquentes que d'habitude
ce n'est qu'après le 40e décès anormal
qu'on s'est posé la question
n'y aurait-il pas un virus particulier à
identifier on fait ça vous êtes certain
d'avoir isolé le virus
christopher ross nous sommes plus que
certains d'avoir isolé le virus
syncytial nous avons isolé non pas sur
un malade mais sur une soixantaine dont
huit se trouvait dans le coma
comment expliquez vous qu'il est une
polémique que votre découvert soit
contesté les organismes officiels
éprouve une certaine difficulté à
admettre que notre laboratoire réussi à
trouver le virus en si peu de temps et
grâce à une technique moderne
la municipalité a commencé à installer
un égout il ya deux ans les travaux se
sont arrêtés
c'est une véritable infection qui
s'attaque aux enfants ces enfants qui
vivent avec des rares grands comme le
bras
à naples la colère ne se transforme
jamais en révolte se révolter contre qui
contre l'état qui existent si peu contre
la municipalité qui devait détruire le
tir de la ville car comment assainir un
tel foyer d'infection
peut-on exiger des mers napolitaine
qu'elles envoient leurs enfants à
l'hôpital avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
trop tard c'est quand exactement
naples a toujours été la mauvaise
conscience de l'italie mais personne
n'imagine que cela puisse changer
entendions sénateurs au japon 40e décès
très rapidement le temps de demain si
bien toujours doux et pluvieux les
innovations sont harraga sion mais on
attend de la pluie sur les côtes de la
manche dans le nord-est et 20 nord du
pays et dans les alpes toujours des
risques d'avalanches ce journal est
terminé de rendez vous demain 12h45
patrick lecocq et 20 heures je serai là
bonsoir à tous